we got some bad ideas in my head when I
teach screenwriting I usually for the
first class I give a sort of lecture
like this one and then I ask everyone to
write down and no more than two
sentences each they're two most pressing
personal problems at this moment you
talking to me and I really don't care if
you guys can write or not because you
can learn to write what I care about is
your problems and the one thing that you
have that is unique to you is your
problem because even if it's the same
problem as a guy next to you self-image
I can't tell my parents I'm gay whatever
your problem is minority anger it's not
exactly the same as the person next to
you because everybody has a different
gradation and if you can refine what's
unique about your problem and one of the
ways you refine this is through the
metaphor then you have a Channel of
uniqueness and then you're doing
something that only you're doing